This is 99% invisible. Eat one the bread. I'm Roman Mars. When I think about white bread, I usually think of wonder bread, and I can picture the loaves all lined up on the grocery store shelves in perfect uniform rows. The red, yellow, and blue circles on the wonder bread label were supposed to conjure balloons floating away, taking us somewhere, somewhere wondrous, somewhere better. The first print advertisement for Wonder Bread, which actually came out before the bread itself, stated only that a wonder was coming.
这里是99%隐形。吃一片面包。我是罗曼·马尔斯。当我想到白面包时，我通常会想到“奇迹面包”（Wonder Bread），我能想象出它们在杂货店货架上整齐排列的样子。奇迹面包标签上的红、黄、蓝圆圈本意是让人联想到飘走的气球，带我们去某个地方，某个奇妙的地方，某个更好的地方。奇迹面包的第一则印刷广告，实际上是在面包本身问世之前就发布了，上面只写着“奇迹即将到来”。
That's Wonder Boy's Sam Greenspan. And in a lot of ways in its time, Wonder Bread really was a wonder. It was the perfect loaf. But now, white bread, and not just wonder bread, but really any brand of industrially produced white bread, it's thought of by food purists as part of a problem. The problem being that we don't know where our food comes from, and we might be consuming impure and unhealthy ingredients. The funny thing is, industrial white bread, that evenly sliced, squishy, moist, perfectly
那是“奇迹男孩”萨姆·格林斯潘。在很多方面，奇迹面包在当时确实是一个奇迹。它是完美的面包。但现在，白面包——不仅仅是奇迹面包，而是任何工业化生产的白面包——被食品纯粹主义者视为一个问题的一部分。问题在于我们不知道食物的来源，而且我们可能正在摄入不纯净和不健康的成分。有趣的是，工业化白面包，那种切片均匀、松软、湿润、完美
white and wondrous loaf was once the highly designed solution to that very same problem. You want to grow bigger and stronger, don't you? Go! Sure! OK, a sandwich daily in two slices of wonder bread every meal gives you eight elements you need. For much of human history, bread has been, and still is, one of the most important foods. Our human ancestors 30,000 years ago
洁白而奇妙的面包，曾经是解决这一问题的精心设计方案。你想长得更高更壮，对吧？去吧！当然！好的，每天吃两片奇迹面包，每顿饭都能为你提供所需的八种元素。在人类历史的大部分时间里，面包一直并将继续是最重要的食物之一。我们的人类祖先在3万年前
had a crude form of bread, nearly every culture on earth has some form of bread, and the importance of bread is, shall we say, baked into language. Take, for instance, the word companion. If we take the word companion back to its Latin roots, we get calm, which is with and pan, which is bread. So a companion is someone that you sit down and you break bread with. That's our guide to all things bread, Aaron Bobro Strain. He's the author of the book,
就有了原始形式的面包，地球上几乎每种文化都有某种形式的面包，而且面包的重要性，我们可以说，已经“烘焙”进了语言中。以“同伴”（companion）这个词为例。如果我们追溯“companion”的拉丁词根，我们会得到“calm”，意思是“一起”，以及“pan”，意思是“面包”。所以，同伴就是和你坐在一起分享面包的人。这是我们关于面包一切事物的向导，亚伦·鲍勃罗-斯特雷恩。他是这本书的作者，
White Bread, a social history of the store bought loaf. In his book, Aaron also talks about the word Lord. It White bread a social history of the store bought loaf in his book Aaron also talks about the word Lord. It comes from a word in Old English I'm not sure how to pronounce it exactly but on paper. It looks like Clafford H. L. A. F. O. R. D Clafford and that meant the keeper of bread or the person who gives bread And that's striking because it it tells us the very act of political rule was wrapped up in the bread supply. Plus, think of all the ways that bread comes up culturally.
《白面包：商店购买面包的社会史》。在他的书中，亚伦还谈到了“领主”（Lord）这个词。它来自古英语中的一个词，我不确定该怎么准确发音，但在书面上，它看起来像“Clafford”，即L-A-F-O-R-D，Clafford，意思是面包的守护者或提供面包的人。这很引人注目，因为它告诉我们，政治统治的行为本身就与面包供应紧密相连。此外，想想面包在文化中出现的各种方式。
Catholics believe that the communion bread transubstantiate into the body of Christ. There's the Lord's Prayer, Matthew 6-11, give us today our daily bread. The Jewish holiday of Passover, centers around the preparation of bread, and on and on. In the Middle Ages, most people got something like 80% of their calories from bread. Fast forward a millennium or so, in the late 19th century, people were still getting about 30% of their calories from bread. That's so much bread, that's bread at every meal, and some meals that were only bread.
天主教徒相信圣餐面包会转化为基督的身体。有《主祷文》，马太福音6章11节，“赐给我们今日的日用饮食”。犹太人的逾越节假期以准备面包为中心，诸如此类。在中世纪，大多数人大约80%的热量来自面包。快进一千年左右，在19世纪末，人们仍有约30%的热量来自面包。那是太多的面包了，那是每顿饭都有面包，有些餐点甚至只有面包。
For most of our long history with bread, the bread we ate was made in our homes. Eventually, we had small bakeries that supplied bread for more people, but they weren't exactly a picture of our Tisnal purity. 100 plus years ago, bakeries were generally dirty and often underground, usually with terrible working conditions, and you never knew when the baker would cut costs by cutting the dough with sawdust or some other horrible additives. During the time we're talking about the late 1800s, early 1900s, there was a lot of foodborne illness, cholera and typhus. A lot of Americans were starting to fear their food, and for good reason, Your food could kill you.
在我们与面包漫长的历史中，大部分时间里，我们吃的面包都是在家里制作的。最终，我们有了为更多人供应面包的小型面包店，但它们并不完全是卫生纯净的典范。100多年前，面包店通常很脏，而且往往在地下，工作条件通常很糟糕，你永远不知道面包师什么时候会为了削减成本而在面团里掺入锯末或其他可怕的添加剂。在我们谈论的19世纪末、20世纪初，有很多食源性疾病，如霍乱和伤寒。许多美国人开始害怕他们的食物，这是有充分理由的，你的食物可能会杀死你。
Middle and upper class white native born Americans during that period go through this kind of freak out about the safety of their bread and you see newspaper headlines during this time screaming. Dangerous bread threatens the city germs Germs, menace your loaf. Things like that. And people who were really freaked out, you know, every city was holding major hearings on the bread question. The neighborhood bakery that we romanticized today was this specter of fear and terror.
那一时期的中上层阶级白人本土美国人对面包的安全性感到恐慌，你可以看到当时报纸头条大声疾呼：“危险的面包威胁城市”、“细菌，威胁你的面包”等等。那些真正感到恐慌的人，你知道，每个城市都在就面包问题举行重大听证会。我们今天浪漫化的社区面包店，在当时是恐惧和恐怖的幽灵。
And so people started getting really interested in where their food came from, kind of like people are doing right now. Only to them. Knowing where their food came from meant actively avoiding locally baked bread. Factory bread, the thinking went, was born not of unclean hands and an underground furnace, but in a modern, light-filled, palace of industry. These palaces of industry would supply bread to the masses, and this bread would be white.
于是人们开始真正关心食物的来源，就像人们现在所做的那样。只是对他们来说，了解食物的来源意味着主动避免当地烘焙的面包。人们认为，工厂面包不是诞生于不洁的手和地下炉灶，而是诞生于现代、光线充足的工业宫殿。这些工业宫殿将为大众供应面包，而这种面包将是白色的。
Bread is a delicious food. Its flavor blends perfectly with other foods, adding zest and enjoyment to any meal. White flour and white bread aren't recent technological innovations in and of themselves. They've been around for millennia. Technically speaking, white flour is whole wheat flour with the brand and the germ from the wheat kernel of sifted out. Industrial bakers chose white bread as their flagship
面包是一种美味的食物。它的味道与其他食物完美融合，为任何餐点增添风味和乐趣。白面粉和白面包本身并不是最近的技术创新。它们已经存在了几千年。从技术上讲，白面粉是去除了麸皮和胚芽的小麦粉。工业面包师选择白面包作为他们的旗舰
bread because for them, white was a marker of purity and cleanliness and modernity. And if this sentiment sounds vaguely racist to you. Well, the racism was more than vague. Dr. Woods Hutchinson, who was a noted health columnist in new syndicated columnist in newspapers, argued that only white bread would fortify the white race to do the things it had to do and go out and conquer other peoples. And if that's not revolting enough?
产品，因为对他们来说，白色是纯洁、清洁和现代的标志。如果这种情绪听起来让你觉得有点种族主义，嗯，这种种族主义不仅仅是模糊的。伍兹·哈钦森博士，一位著名的报纸健康专栏作家，曾主张只有白面包才能增强白人的体质，让他们去做必须做的事情，去征服其他民族。如果这还不够令人反感的话？
Food reformers of the day referring to the white loaf as a chased loaf and the dark loaf as a defiled loaf. And bread was actually never a real vector for a contagion. That was mostly the meat and dairy supply, which is why Aaron Bobro strain argues that this fear over the safety of bread wasn't actually about bread. What I started to realize was that it had become impossible in in native born middle and upper class whites, minds to separate fears about bread safety from their fears about immigration, particularly the new southern and eastern European immigrants,
当时的食品改革者将白面包称为“纯洁的面包”，将黑面包称为“受污染的面包”。事实上，面包从来都不是传染病的真正媒介。那主要是肉类和乳制品供应的问题，这就是为什么亚伦·鲍勃罗-斯特雷恩认为，这种对面包安全性的恐惧实际上与面包无关。我开始意识到，在本土出生的中上层阶级白人的头脑中，已经不可能将对面包安全的恐惧与对移民的恐惧分开了，特别是那些新的南欧和东欧移民，
who was supposedly dirty and diseased hands, were touching bread in neighborhood bakeries. Basically, Aaron believes that our attraction to white bread came from real fears about food contagion that got mixed up unfairly with fears about immigrants. It was a shining, white, clean, modern marvel, untouched by human hands. That was the antithesis of that scary, supposedly dirty and diseased product of immigration. And because white bread was white, the thinking went, you knew it was free of dirt and other contaminants, which you might fear from your local bakery.
他们被认为肮脏且带有疾病的手在社区面包店触摸面包。基本上，亚伦认为我们对白面包的吸引力源于对食物传染的真实恐惧，这种恐惧被不公平地与对移民的恐惧混为一谈。它是一个闪亮、洁白、现代的奇迹，未被人类之手触碰。那是对那种可怕的、被认为肮脏且带有疾病的移民产品的反面。而且因为白面包是白色的，人们认为，你就知道它没有污垢和其他污染物，而这些正是你可能从当地面包店担心的。
Its whiteness was thus its proof of purity. Now that logic is kind of flawed because lots of the adulterants that bakers used were white, chalk, alum. The bleach white loaf just needed one more thing before it could fully embody our need for uniformity. It needed to be sliced. Which brings us to a summer day in 1928. Let's say July 7, 1928. On that day, it was July 7, I checked.
因此，它的洁白就是它纯洁的证明。现在，这种逻辑有点缺陷，因为面包师使用的许多掺假物也是白色的，比如白垩、明矾。漂白的白面包在完全体现我们对统一性的需求之前，还需要一件事。它需要被切片。这把我们带到了1928年的一个夏日。让我们说是1928年7月7日。在那一天，确实是7月7日，我核实过了。
In the town of Chilacothe, Missouri, people had gathered at first in Elm streets and they were lined up around the block. I don't know if there were lines down the block. Those weren't described, but people were certainly eager to see this. However, they were gathered. People were there to witness the advent
在密苏里州的奇利科西镇，人们聚集在埃尔姆街，他们排成了长队。我不知道是否排到了街区外。那些没有被描述，但人们肯定很渴望看到这个。无论如何，他们聚集在一起。人们在那里见证了
of packaged, pre-sliced bread. One reporter in Chilacati, Missouri spoke of housewives who were visiting this bakery to see this sliced bread, how they had this thrill of enthusiasm, and were just awestruck by this perfectly sliced bread. It was a small, edible vision of progress and the future. People like sliced bread so much. I can't overstate how much they loved it and how quickly it caught on. It was the best thing since I can't even think
包装好的预切片面包的问世。密苏里州奇利科西的一位记者谈到，家庭主妇们参观这家面包店观看这种切片面包时，她们表现出一种热情的激动，并被这种完美切片的面包所震撼。这是一个微小的、可食用的进步和未来的愿景。人们非常喜欢切片面包。我无法夸大他们有多喜欢它，以及它传播得有多快。这是自……以来最好的东西，我甚至想不出
of another thing that was quite as good. Industrial bakers had the hype. They had the sense of moral mission and they had the design parameters. White bread in streamlined loaves with uniform slices. But the science of industrializing and mass producing bread was still a little wacky. Bread after all is the product of microorganisms going through biological processes. Bread
还有什么东西能像它一样好。工业面包师拥有炒作。他们有道德使命感，也有设计参数。白面包是流线型的，切片均匀。但工业化和大规模生产面包的科学仍然有点古怪。毕竟，面包是微生物经历生物过程的产物。面包
is a function of time and temperature and a lot of other variables. In fact, bread was one of the last major foods to get industrialized, precisely because of how complex it is to make uniformly. The assembly process was really different than, say, making a car. Imagine if Henry Ford every time he wanted to make a car had to worry about the fact that his parts might grow or shrink depending on the temperature and humidity that day, that a gust of air coming through the factory might cause his car to deflate.
是时间、温度和许多其他变量的函数。事实上，面包是最后几种实现工业化的主要食品之一，正是因为它制作起来非常复杂，难以统一。组装过程与制造汽车真的不同。想象一下，如果亨利·福特每次想制造一辆汽车时，都必须担心他的零件可能会根据当天的温度和湿度而膨胀或收缩，或者一阵风吹进工厂可能会导致他的汽车瘪掉。
These were the kind of biological questions that early industrial bakers had to figure out. And so from the 1920s and 30s onward, industrial bakers were constantly tinkering with the design of white bread. They cut the time it took for the bread to rise by adding sugars and cranking up the temperature. They added emulsifiers to allow the dough's water and fat to mix together better. Giving white bread its height and more even grain. That also got rid soft whipped. Eventually, vitamins were added and sold to the public as a means of making hardy young men
这些是早期工业面包师必须解决的生物学问题。因此，从20世纪20年代和30年代开始，工业面包师不断地修补白面包的设计。他们通过添加糖和提高温度来缩短面包发酵的时间。他们添加乳化剂，使面团中的水和脂肪混合得更好。赋予白面包高度和更均匀的纹理。这也去除了柔软的口感。最终，维生素被添加进去，并作为让强壮的年轻人变得
who would be fit to fight in the war. Two slices of wonder bread every meal give you as much phosphorus for cell metabolism as this egg, as much iron for red blood as three lamb chops, as much niacin for metal health, as six sardines, as much energy as two glasses of milk. Little by little various factories created their own recipes and innovations for industrial white bread and all of that came to a head in 1952 in Rockford, Illinois.
适合参战的手段向公众推销。每顿饭两片奇迹面包为你提供与这颗鸡蛋一样多的磷用于细胞代谢，与三块羊排一样多的铁用于红细胞，与六条沙丁鱼一样多的烟酸用于心理健康，与两杯牛奶一样多的能量。一点一点地，各个工厂创造了他们自己的工业白面包配方和创新，所有这些在1952年的伊利诺伊州罗克福德达到了顶峰。
The USDA in cooperation with key figures of the industrial baking world. Put together a multi-year project that I kind of jokingly refer to as the Manhattan Project of Bread. A multi-year panoramic investigation of bread and bread eating habits. And the ultimate goal of the project was to design the perfect loaf of white bread. It involved focus groups, market research, double blind taste tests. The end product of the so-called Manhattan Project of Bread was a white bread two and a half times as sweet as the average loaf available at the time. And 40% fluffier, too.
美国农业部与工业烘焙界的关键人物合作。开展了一个多年项目，我开玩笑地称之为“面包的曼哈顿计划”。这是一个关于面包和面包食用习惯的多年全景调查。该项目的最终目标是设计出完美的白面包。它涉及焦点小组、市场研究、双盲口味测试。所谓的“面包曼哈顿计划”的最终产品是一种比当时市面上平均面包甜2.5倍的白面包。而且蓬松度也增加了40%。
The fluffier the manufacturers made the bread, the more people wanted to buy it, even though the Rockford research also showed that they didn't really like it. They just couldn't resist the fluff. Consumers are choosing the fluffier bread, but not particularly liking its texture. But yet they were eating it in large quantities, about a pound and a half per person per week. Not too long after the Rockford study closes shop, White bread goes through an identity crisis. Where it was once a feel good symbol of progress,
制造商把面包做得越蓬松，人们就越想买，尽管罗克福德的研究也表明他们并不真正喜欢它。他们只是无法抗拒那种蓬松感。消费者选择了更蓬松的面包，但并不特别喜欢它的口感。然而，他们却大量食用，每人每周约1.5磅。在罗克福德研究结束后不久，白面包经历了一场身份危机。它曾经是进步的象征，让人感觉良好，
White bread began to get used as an epithet, meaning, you know, stuffy, conservative, square, white suburban. In 1970, when Richard Pryor in a fit storms off the stage of his popular show at the Aladdin Theatre in Las Vegas saying that he is absolutely done with this white bread humor. From around that point forward, countercultural movements used white bread as an emblem of the establishment of the silent majority of Richard Nixon's
白面包开始被用作一个贬义词，意思是，你知道，古板、保守、刻板、白人郊区。1970年，当理查德·普赖尔在拉斯维加斯阿拉丁剧院的流行演出中愤怒地冲下舞台，说他彻底受够了这种“白面包式幽默”。从那时起，反主流文化运动将白面包用作建制派的象征，即理查德·尼克松的“沉默的大多数”的象征。
America. But then, by the 1980s, 1990s, the meaning starts to bifurcate. It also starts to take on the significance of white trash. So white bread starts to stand in for a poor white person who is making supposedly irresponsible decisions about diet and about their life. So I was fascinated by the way that white bread could mean essentially the opposite of itself. Both affluent and suburban and poor and rural. If there's one lesson from Aaron Bobro's trains research, it's that this debate over which kind of bread to eat, white or wheat, it's not new.
美国。但到了20世纪80年代、90年代，其含义开始分化。它也开始带上“白垃圾”（white trash）的含义。所以白面包开始代表一个贫穷的白人，他在饮食和生活中做出了被认为是不负责任的决定。所以我对白面包可以意味着与其自身完全相反的东西感到着迷。既是富裕和郊区的，又是贫穷和农村的。如果说亚伦·鲍勃罗-斯特雷恩的研究有一个教训，那就是关于吃哪种面包——白面包还是全麦面包——的争论并不新鲜。
In fact, it goes back thousands of years. In Plato's Republic, Plato sets up this kind of debate about whether the ideal polys, the ideal society or city state, should function on a diet of whole grain, gruel associated with rural life, or kind of acidified white bread cakes. But what's most interesting about these debates in history says Aaron, is that they are often about everything except bread. So in Plato's case, even back then it was really not about the healthiness of bread so much as it was about anxieties about whether the Athens was losing moral virtue because
事实上，它可以追溯到几千年前。在柏拉图的《理想国》中，柏拉图提出了关于理想城邦（理想社会或城市国家）应该以与农村生活相关的全麦粥为食，还是以酸化的白面包饼为食的辩论。但亚伦说，这些历史辩论中最有趣的是，它们通常与面包无关。所以在柏拉图的例子中，即使在当时，这也不是关于面包的健康问题，而是关于雅典是否正在失去道德美德的焦虑，因为
it was becoming less connected to the land. We see that debates about white bread and brown bread get tied up into large questions about what do people think about progress? What do people think about industrialization, class and hierarchy? The point is, is that when we're worrying about whether or not we should eat white bread or brown bread, it's usually about much larger questions. We can learn something about our own society, our own anxieties and aspirations by looking at 99% Invisible with Produce this Week by Sam Greenspan And here's Sam Lee really going to town on Wonderred With Katie Mingle, Avery Trouffleman and me Roman Mars
它与土地的联系越来越少。我们看到，关于白面包和黑面包的争论与人们对进步的看法、对工业化、阶级和等级制度的看法等大问题联系在一起。重点是，当我们担心是否应该吃白面包或黑面包时，通常涉及的是更大的问题。通过观察《99%隐形》，我们可以了解我们自己的社会、我们自己的焦虑和抱负。本周由萨姆·格林斯潘制作，萨姆·李在这里与凯蒂·明格、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼和我罗曼·马尔斯一起，真正地大谈特谈奇迹面包。
It is based on an interview we heard on Benjamin Walker's theory of everything a fine radiotopia program that you should already love on Benjamin's most recent episode, we tell the story of how Benjamin and I first met 14 years ago and started immediately conspiring to make something like we've made in radio toopia today a place where the most creative radio makers produce directly for the most curious and engaged listeners. You should check it out. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and produced out of the offices of Arxin, an architecture firm in beautiful downtown Raycat country, Oakland, California.
它基于我们在本杰明·沃克的《万物理论》中听到的采访，这是一个你应该已经喜欢的优秀Radiotopia节目。在本杰明最近的一集中，我们讲述了本杰明和我14年前第一次见面，并立即开始密谋制作像我们今天在Radiotopia所做的那样的事情——一个让最有创意的广播制作人为最好奇、最投入的听众直接制作内容的地方。你应该去看看。我们是旧金山91.7地方公共广播电台KALW的一个项目，在美丽的奥克兰市中心，雷卡特县的Arxin建筑事务所办公室制作。
You can follow along this show on Facebook, Twitter, and Tumblr and everything you ever need to know about this show. You can find out on 99pi.org. Thanks. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Facebook、Twitter和Tumblr上关注这个节目，关于这个节目你需要知道的一切，你都可以在99pi.org上找到。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。